in other world news Japan's prime
minister says the latest test firing of
ballistic missiles by North Korea is a
grave violation of U.N resolutions the
Japanese government says two missiles
flew around 900 kilometers before
landing within its exclusive economic
zone in the Sea of Japan let's go live
to Fadi salami who's in Tokyo fatty what
more are Japanese officials saying about
this latest launch by the North Koreans
when we're receiving more details from
Japan's defense Ministry about the
course and the the size of these two
missiles apparently as you mentioned
they traveled between 800 and 100
kilometers and there is an altitude of
50 kilometers before falling 250
kilometers 250 kilometers of Ishikawa
prefecture Northwest of Japan this is a
great concern for Japan as the Japanese
forces have been on high alert they have
been expecting that North Korea would
fire another ballistic missile that
North Korea was claims to be carrying a
military satellite the window which
North Korea has announced for such
experiments after the fail of the first
experiment on the 31st of May the end of
last month expired on the 11th of June
still the Japanese government was on
High level and these two missiles they
fell in the executive in the exclusive
economic zone of Japan and such
incidents hasn't happened for over six
months the timing of such experiments by
North Korea is very very interesting
actually because today in the morning in
North Korea's spokesperson military
spokesperson accused South Korea and the
United States of escalating the
situation by doing their Maneuvers and
training over the last three weeks it
was the largest such training military
training since six years but for Japan
the timing is also interesting because
tomorrow the Japanese Parliament is
going to vote on new bills for
increasing the Japan's defense
capabilities okay fatty thank you very
much for the update Faris salame live
there in Tokyo